I did not I was not ready for one-on-one
circling at all there's like so much
different a group certainly group
certainly you can kind of hang back
chill no worries someone else is gonna
talk I don't need to necessarily engage
directly but when your one-on-one
circling it's just so much different
though those those were my first two
times doing it you have to be engaged
you have to be in their world you have
to be and ready to you know to to
paraphrase how they're feeling and then
to and then to ask them a question about
how they're feeling and then maybe even
asking a question that leads them down a
path affect that that hasn't opened up
in a even more vulnerable and beautiful
way and so I was totally not expecting
all of that crazy pressure and
difference and it is it is fun though
you know it's a lot of dance but you
know when you you know the first time
you start trying to dance people are
like who's that guy once you hit the
dance floor like a hundred times
eventually I'll have danced a hundred
times you will feel better and then
you'll dance ten thousand times that
you'll be really good at it and then but
that's it's fun being in that position
and it's fun having a one on a circle
being done to you as well you're
surrendering to just one person rather
than six people so it's interesting how
the people dynamics changed based on n
base
number of people that are in the circle
like if you were to get circled right
now it would be like 20 people so it's
just it's one-on-one to 20 is its these
scales are so fascinating so the scale
was an interesting analysis to have a
question for you
so save it the safety to save it you
like well first of all I think it's so
revealing that like you said like how
like intense it was a neighbor like a
nurse fun I gave you eight points to it
points to like it puts to that something
feels worth the discomfort oh yeah what
like if we just like imagine you went
through the discomfort and it became one
of those you're dancin like an hour from
now or five years from now and now
that's just background that's a pre
reflective response you know what a
world is you know you could be there all
that stuff what that is why would you
want that
like what's cool about that for you well
where's that giving I guess be analogous
to to speaking or to language if you
were never taught language when you were
a child you would not have this ability
to vibrate vocal cords in you to
understand something of thought and so
same thing goes for a computer we see
people constantly finger poking at a
keyboard and like then that's the
universe is typing at 100 words per
minute or whatever so the idea of my
life being so much more my reasoning
down the road because I've learned
language I've learned how to type fast
on the keyboard it just accelerates my
my ability to enrich humanity so much
more to provide to the collective to
provide to myself so much better that is
why I go through the processes of being
super duper uncomfortable with starting
things first time second time fall on
your face fall on your face and then you
get and then you learn from that you you
love it because you
from it and then you take those lessons
you apply in your life you keep
practicing keep practicing and then the
that background music down the line once
it's once it's a year down the line and
it doesn't you it's a part of your
rhythm it's a part of your cadence what
you're doing every single moment of time
it just that's worth it all that is
worth it all it's such a beautiful life
story to be able to paint out versus
saying if you let that fear absorb you
and if you let that fear impede you from
further developing yourself out down the
line it will be a regret it's inevitable
that way